hughes are in and viva by ray garcia at
resorts world goes beyond your
traditional mexican fair here to tell us
more about it is peter carrillo one of
the partners and lead mixologist michael
monreal welcome you guys yeah how are
you thank you for having us thanks for
being here can you give us the overview
of the restaurant what do we expect when
we walk in you know viva for us we
wanted to create like a fun lively
environment really something for
everyone for the most part and i think
the main thing about viva is we wanted
it to be approachable so when you walk
in you know it's kind of this oaxaca
meets tulum kind of decor vibe really
intimate bar scene you know um beautiful
patio on las vegas boulevard you know
we've got different little pockets of
areas of viva if you want to have a
formal dining experience spot for that
but if you want to be part of the bar
scene kind of a little more of energy
you know really caters to everything and
ray garcia sheriff garcia is a legendary
chef tell me more about him chef ray's
got an interesting story he actually
went to school to be a lawyer and then
after he graduated ucla he enrolled in
culinary school
he landed his first job at the peninsula
in beverly hills and worked his way
through the ranks and became an
executive chef and then in 2015 opened
broken spanish in downtown l.a
um and then the following year i swear
magazine named him uh chef of the year i
love that tell us more about the menu
and some of the food items you have this
looks delicious yeah yeah the menu these
are some of our highlight dishes that we
have at viva uh our tuna tostada here
heirloom corn tostada
big-eyed tuna heirloom tomato um also a
cashew crema with a little chill in it
so it's got a little heat it's nice
little refreshing light dish for the
spring
the snappers are on the auto two pound
red snapper uh we do it on our wood this
is one one dish i mean that was gonna be
a family of five right there that's a
huge surprise two pounds so two pounds
of snapper we do it on a wood grill
finish it off with a little chili
toriado this is definitely chef rey's
signature dish this is his chicharron so
this takes almost five days to prepare
and make and after it's marinated for a
couple days slow cooked for about 36
hours we make it a cheat drone and
finish it by frying it yeah so when you
bite into it you've got that nice
crackly crunch from this exterior but
it's just
amazingly juicy
for five days
i want to get to michael before we wrap
things up here talk about your signature
cocktails that you guys have there uh we
have a little bit for everybody we have
a um clearly
the mascala and tequila highlight that
customized chef ray's um so you make one
now as we're here to watch your edition
once you work your magic um yeah we're
gonna make our signature vivorita to
start with a casa del sol blanco
which is a unique ultra premium tequila
that is aged in cognac barrels as
opposed to the traditional
uh whiskey barrels that they
traditionally use i like how everything
on the menu has a back story behind yeah
this is really now when you walk in
what's the first drink what what do you
recommend what's the go to the airport
it's this one it's the vivarita and
something else about this too is we we
do all our cocktails for a lot of our
sporty cocktails in a keg so you know
the goal is you sit down you order a
vivoita or one of these other cocktails
and you've got that thing in front of
you in 20 30 seconds yeah we've all been
to bars we can take
five to ten minutes to make one cocktail
and nobody wants this amazing dish takes
five days to prepare yeah your cocktails
don't take five days yeah you gotta put
the table within within 15 seconds well
then shake it up there my man get it
michael
could do the quick point i got to wrap
it up here i want to see what this looks
like the finished product some fresh ice
in the drink we're inside resource world
it's a beautiful property where do i go
inside the property i can't miss it as
soon as you're walking now resorts world
it's called the district it's basically
like a restaurant row so we're right
next to that big globe sphere of the
shore that you have in there but katmas
viva debt center when you're walking
straight down i was looking online for
the photos to instagram worthy spot as
well yeah it's an instagram where
they're beautiful we wrapped there with
a drink
yep perfect as about michael's finish it
off to try it during the break it looks
so it looks delicious is it done yep
send it over here my friend thank you so
much michael peter viva thank you so
much thank you resort world is where you
find them las vegas now we'll be right
back
[Music]